the explain series is back
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and ever
since my super nexus project video i've
gotten a lot of questions about what
exactly it means to root an android
device and we'll cover the jailbreaking
part in the end but basically people
want to know what exactly it means and
what it entails to root an android
device so by definition root is having
the ability to write to the root of the
system partition that's the basic
definition of what it means and once
you've rooted you've opened up a whole
bunch of different possibilities that
allow you to do a ton of different
things and allow a little bit more
control over your phone or tablet or any
android device once you root you can get
rid of all those pesky carrier installed
pre-installed apps that you don't want
and you can install and use a bunch of
only apps that only work on rooted
phones which give you even more control
than you had before as israel from xda
developers points out there are a ton of
great root only apps for your device and
for tons of android stuff if you google
it and frankly it's these features from
these root only apps that end up getting
implemented into newer versions of
android so you used to need root to for
example take screenshots now that's
built in to android you need to need
root to tether with an android device
now that's built into android as well so
if you want to be on the bleeding edge
of features and new customizations and
new things to be able to do with your
android device whether it's a tablet a
camera or a phone or whatever it is look
into rooting and root apps if you want
to backup and restore app data add
themes to android change your boot
animation or change your entire rom
altogether if you want to take a device
running one version of android and flash
and install a newer more updated version
of android without waiting for your
carrier to push it you can do that if
you're rooted so the most common
question after that is how do i root my
device so basically the way to find out
how to root your device since it is just
slightly different for every device is
to google the exact model of the device
you want to root followed by you know
rooting instructions and chances are
you're going to find the exact
instructions you need so for example i
have a verizon samsung galaxy s3 so if i
google how to root verizon samsung
galaxy s3 chances are you're gonna find
a direct set of beginner level
instructions that'll help you figure it
out now yes rooting does void your
warranty but as i like to say you don't
even really own the device until you've
avoided the warranty but chances are if
you do screw up if you have a device
even slightly newer than the original
motorola droid there is a community
behind that to back you up and help you
get fixed problems oh yeah and you can
unroot so
yeah on the ios side it's called
jailbreaking as you probably already
know you can jailbreak iphones ipods and
ipads there's also a huge jailbreak
community as well so if you want to
jailbreak your device it's similar to
rooting it's not technically the same
you know gaining root but it is very
very customizable you can add a whole
bunch of features and things to your
device that weren't previously available
for example in ios you used to need to
be jailbroken to add wallpapers now
that's built in so go figure again
jailbreaking does void your warranty but
if you're up to it google the
instructions for your specific device
and you shouldn't have a problem a lot
of websites are really helpful if you
visit a very certain website on your
device that you want to jailbreak you
can actually just push a button on the
website and it'll jailbreak you through
that website so it's really easy for
both android and ios to get
more control over your device whether
you want to root or jailbreak
it's up to you and for the most part you
can tell if a guide is trustworthy by
reading the comments below it if there
are a lot of comments a lot of success
stories then chances are it's
trustworthy you can go for it so
get cracking either way thanks for
watching this quick video on rooting and
jailbreaking explained it was a pleasure
hopefully you guys go out and uh get
that customization going on your devices
again the super nexus project which you
can click on this device to watch was
done after i rooted the device so once
you root you'll get the control and
you'll be able to do all these things
either way thanks for watching hope you
enjoy the video and i will talk to you
guys in the very next one which should
be sort of a collab video so hope you're
ready for that
peace
you